à lui comme avoir pris seulement sur mon
dos ne pas en parler parce que voilà
alors dit la vérité puisqu'il s'est
versé un scot qu'est ce qui s'est passé
fneg lopez a dit préférer yann barthès à
vous parce que vous étiez en dessous de
nuit et pas très drôle ça vole et plus
ça va aller plus loin on à l'extrême et
donc dis moi c'est ma promo c'est le
regarde j'ai vu l'émission et
franchement c'est pas terrible
l'émission de tout ce qui s'est passé ce
matin l'ex rennais attend avant dans
l'extrait d'accord ce matin je ne
regarde jamais ses news
je te jure par hasard j'allume la télé
je tombe sur ses news yach mcmordie qui
cartonne et jean marc morandini je
regarde y'a frédéric lopez qui parle de
l'émission de ce soir et il lui fait un
quiz il lui dit vous préférez ceux
présents de temps mais ça arrive là toi
vous référez yann barthès vous préférez
cyril hanouna way et il dit ben je
préfère yann barthès dans ma tête je me
dis arrête toi là c'est le matin je suis
aussi avec des miel pops je regarde ça
je me tiendrai toi lie à l'émission ce
soir
et là jean marc morandini est mourant
digne et google a l'air tout ça pourquoi
mon préféré yann barthès dans ma tête je
me dis répond parce que parce que ne va
pas plus loin et il dit parce que ça
vole plus haut ouais je me suis dit
rajoute un truc des oiseaux il a mis les
oiseaux nés un bouton ni rien du tout il
est allé la tête j'appelle franck ouais
j'ai dit franck sûr que c'est vrai et si
franck je parie que ce soir cyril il
parle pas de terrain connu parce que
parce que près de lopez il a dit qu'il
préférait yann barthès prend qui me dit
mais jamais de la vie
jamais de la vie cyril il s'en fout il a
d'autres choses à faire
j'ai le message que tu m'as envoyé
[Rires]
attends je vais te retrouver le message
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas j'appelle et
j'appelle franck à 13h15
13h39 message de cyril hanouna guerrero
je ne fais aucune promo ce soir pour le
crédit on pèse et battu je trouve cet
abruti de frais de la basse mathieu je
te dit quelque chose et c'est ça ça m'a
pas plus abattu que je te dise la vérité
ouais c'est que c'est un deuxième cache
pour toi parce que fred lopez il avec
nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
basket avec lui entre nous est-ce que ça
va mon frère on va oui alors évidemment
syrie c'était une blague
c'est un coup monté et il avait compris
je rigole pas s'accoupler la tête des
vidéos au relais on avoir fait des frets
je voulais te dire mais taxi ça sort
demain ou pas je suis dans le truman
show je voulais dire que tu fais ton
émission est exceptionnel ce soir avec
manny qu est ce que tu peux nous en dire
deux mots et nous dire comment ça s'est
passé avec madic parce que c'est fou ce
qui s'est passé plus des chats ils
croyaient partir très très loin et
finalement non tu la mettes dans les
cévennes et je sais qu'il vous l'avait
raconté dans le détail effectivement
donc il raconte mieux - et ce qui est
fou c'est que m'a dit que vous allez le
voir demain dans un blockbuster dans
taxi est bien là dans nos terres
inconnues vous le verrez dans les
cascades à 12° vous le montrez vous le
verrez monter à cheval et sans cascadeur
donc sans doublure je vous laisse vous
raconter comment ça s'est passé
et vous dire que malik a peur de tout
c'est un euphémisme franchement frédéric
je vais te dire l'émission il paraît que
la litote
tout le monde a adoré l'émission je suis
sûr qu'il va faire un carton d'audience
tu sais qu'on est derrière toi frédéric
et j'espère que tu amènera d'autres
potes à moi
loin de tout ça voilà parce que vivre
quand il vit des aventures comme ça
franchement lui ça la change et je te le
dire mais je rigole pas il m'appelait
après il m'a appelé après ils
m'appellent pas pour le tournage m'a pas
plu mais ma paire avons après manif
parec frédéric lopez jeu plus pouvoir
d'avoir pendant longtemps et quand il
est revenu et m'a dit je suis pas parti
loin mais il m'a raconté
es-tu là tu l'a vraiment changer encore
tu lui apporter encore je pensais avoir
pris plein de chocs tout cas merci
franchement cyril pour la blagounette de
ce matin parce que c'est un coup monté
évidemment avec morandini vous l'avez
compris c'est pour faire le buzz pour
faire peur à malik
évidemment vous le savez que ça vole
plus haut chez vous qu'ailleurs mais
enfin ce que vous dites dans l'émission
césar sur terre inconnue évidemment on
va beaucoup beaucoup rire ça je peux
vous le dire c'est que ma vie comme vous
l'avez jamais vu et d'ailleurs franck
gastambide a vu terre inconnue c'est
qu'ils en parlent bien ouais c'est
frédéric où sera avec thau soirée juste
après en plus il y aura un débrief en
direct un avec malik haute embrasse très
fort fred merci tu vas pouvoir continuer
[Applaudissements]